there are nine mistakes my head made
ahead of me
and i i will make sure over over the
next decade or so that they they will uh
they will know that they made a mistake
that was salty josh rose and the night
he was drafted by the cardinals he would
thereafter amend his remarks to say well
the only ones that made mistakes were
the ones who needed quarterbacks the
ones who have quarterbacks they didn't
make mistakes but still he was miffed
about what happened then and if he
didn't like that guys he may not like
what's coming if the cardinals take kyle
murray number one overall and then trade
josh rosen to someone else the cardinals
did not attend the calamari pro day
workout last week they didn't need to
because they're having a private workout
in norman oklahoma with him now that's
part of the standard draft process and
you can you can have as many private
workouts as you want to send guys to as
many as you can fit into the calendar
you can go work out whoever you want
they're going to work out kyler murray
they'll have him run some of their plays
they'll let him kind of operate in a far
less public environment than when your
pro day is televised to the world and
they'll they'll continue their process
as doing what they should do the due
diligence making your decision what can
we get for josh rosen what do we have in
kyler murray do we want to make colin
murray the first overall pick and move
on from the guy who was the 10th overall
pick a year ago here's the thing i don't
understand about this cardinals kyler
murray situation
what what are the cardinals gaining from
basically telling the world that they're
going to draft kyle murray number one
right this early that already makes me
throw up a flag and say something is up
yeah and i the only thing i can land on
is the fact that they haven't said that
they haven't said of course they haven't
said it but let's be honest here i mean
everything is pointing to it right like
private workouts like all the rumors
everything feels i mean i'm not saying
the outright have said it but don't you
think that they've made it pretty clear
they're very interested in kyler murray
i i don't know if i will say that i mean
it seems that way but i think we've kind
of let our own brains down that path to
go it seems to make so much sense yeah
but chris chris
you've got you got to take yesterday on
this that i think was very appropriate
the idea that murray's got the demeanor
of a guy who knows that something's up
no no question it does i do feel like i
feel the same way you do like right the
arizona does really want him they're
trying to play their cards close to the
vest uh i i feel like kyla murray is
like just couldn't be less worried about
this whole draft process right like he
knows something we don't know right he
has he walked away from guaranteed money
with baseball i
look back to last year yeah we didn't
know that the browns were gonna take
baker mayfield until what the week of
yeah like it was that was before it was
that close so my bigger point is what
are the cardinals doing with basically
kind of letting this rumor get out there
let this build up they're not they
haven't traded josh rosen yet i think
they're going to wait and see if they
can get if two teams who need
quarterbacks potentially we're gonna see
the raiders with multiple picks in the
first round why wouldn't they just sit
there and say we're gonna try to make
the whole world convinced that if you
want kyle murray you better be number
one yeah trade us one of these picks
trade us two of these picks the raiders
have three picks the giants have two
picks i i just something feels wrong
that the that the cardinals would both
move on from josh rosen so quickly and
also have it be sort of floated out
there that they're taking kylie murray
three months before the draft yeah well
i guess the big thing i don't think they
know what they want to do yeah i really
don't i won't i don't know that for sure
but i'm sure they're still weighing all
the options whether what the market is
for josh rosen if they do dangle him out
there uh for a trade the kyler murray
thing they're certainly doing their due
diligence hey i would argue that nobody
knows kyle murray better than cliff
kingsbury saw him on the field recruited
him coming out of college he understands
what the guy is but still they want to
get a look you know up close in person i
understand that and you know there's
nothing wrong with bringing them in
they're they're again i think the fact
that they're doing this does just drive
up the price because then they're going
to be able to say well we were really
thinking about taking them we wanted
them so if you really want a man you
better throw in that extra second round
pick because i think we're gonna take
him so this is extremely intriguing it
stinks for josh rosen because he is a
good football player i liked him a lot
coming out in the draft last year he's a
little fragile and does lack mobility
the problem is kyla murray as mike has
said a million times has a special skill
set that you just don't see very often
in football and you don't want to be the
team that passed up on them
and here's the other thing to keep in
mind as it relates to the nfl's ultimate
reality show about nothing the first
round of the draft that they don't even
need to do they could do it all by text
message but it's become this monstrous
event they're gonna have 60 000 people
on the streets of nashville for this
draft i think that what the nfl does
every year now with the team that has
the first overall pick i think that team
gets counseled on how to properly play
this game because you don't have any
final idea of who the pick is going to
be until as late as possible the browns
kept it quiet last year big cat as you
said until the week of the draft when
the rams traded up to get jared goff
they refused to say who they were going
to take just to have some shred of drama
that maybe they were going to take
somebody else if you come out and say
you're taking kyle murray right now you
upset the the draft knight apple cart
and that's a huge thing for the nfl now
and it's going to keep getting bigger
and bigger especially once you can start
betting on who the picks are going to be
i love conspiracy theory mike i like
that a lot but
like going against that point doesn't it
feel like they've kind of not said it
but they've kind of said that they're
going to take kyle murray
now they've kind of got it's out there
it's a reality even i mean think about
it they've got their quarterback and
we're regarding it as a very plausible
outcome that they would take kyler
murray whatever they do or don't look at
look at the interest it's driving we're
consuming the the articles that are on
the website on nfl.com and
arizonacardinals.com and
hopefullyprofootballtalk.com we're
watching the pro day workout on nfl
network that's what it's all about it's
about selling something in the off
season when there's no football to sell
more pft live right after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports